desafiando el confinamiento cientos de
manifestantes salieron a las calles de
odiará en contra del gobierno las
autoridades impusieron un cierre de 36
horas para hacer frente a los disturbios
las protestas continuaron un día después
de que los manifestantes intentaran
asaltar el parlamento y derrocar al
primer ministro mal acceso grabar ahora
a petición de su homólogo de las islas
salomón el primer ministro australiano
scott morrison dice que enviará fuerzas
de seguridad para ayudar a controlar los
disturbios
estoy probar nuestro propósito aquí es
proporcionar estabilidad y seguridad
para permitir que los procesos
constitucionales dentro de las islas
salomón sean capaces de hacer frente a
los problemas que han surgido with the
vicious
morrison asegura que el despliegue
australiano será por pocas semanas la
última misión de mantenimiento de la paz
de camberra en las islas fue en 2003 y
duró 14 años hasta que en 2017 los dos
países firmaron un tratado de seguridad
ahora el motivo de las protestas se
centra en las promesas de
infraestructura incumplidas por el
primer ministro por lo que los
manifestantes piden su dimisión además
la decisión del gobierno de primar los
lazos diplomáticos con china sobre
taiwán también ha generado enfado el
barrio chino de on y ahora ha sido el
blanco de las protestas donde se han
incendiado varios edificios y se han
saqueado tiendas la embajada de beijing
ha pedido al gobierno de las islas
salomón que refuerce la protección de
las empresas chinas